comment partager sa propre perception de
la nature par l'art voilà la question
que s'est posée l'artiste mesniloise
valérie d'oiseaux pour le projet aux
artistes le patrimoine du pnr de la
vallée de chevreuse c'est avec une
installation nommée polyphonie
chromatique qui prendra place à la ferme
de bourrins qu'elle tente d'y répondre
quand ce projet de darré patrimoine a
été proposé j'ai perçu ça comme un
insigne habitant juste à côté qui avait
la ferme qui était juste à côté
travaillant sur le thème deschamps
puisque ça fait deux ans que dans mon
processus de travail la couleur apparaît
je me suis proposé pour ce projet j'ai
rédigé donc un dossier qui explicite et
l'idée de départ que le principe c'était
d'essayer de faire percevoir à la fois
la tonalité des chants toute la variété
que peuvent prendre les couleurs et les
graphismes champêtre mais en même temps
comment une architecture rural qui n'a
pas entre guillemets un but esthétique à
sa propre harmonie esthétique une ferme
elle est d'abord construite pour sa
nécessité son principe d'existence et
pas pour sa beauté comme un château où
on cherche plus à à une esthétique une
harmonie à un équilibre là l'équilibré
dans sa fonctionnalité
suite à une grande période d'observation
de cet espace à différentes saisons
valérie a choisi de mettre en place 16
grandes gravure peintes sur les
ouvertures de la ferme
une technique mûrement réfléchie pour
proposer une double lecture à cette
oeuvre est le principe du projet c'est
que la vision va être à deux
possibilités on va voir là les grandes
peintures et les gravures de la route
donc à une centaine de mètres donc là on
aura que des monochromes de couleurs et
plus on va s'approcher de la de la ferme
et des murs et la plus on va rentrer
dans le graphisme de la gravure et on va
apercevoir les subtilités des motifs
quand je suis dans les champs belges
éprouvent des émotions des sensations
autant par la lumière que par la couleur
du coup j'essaie de voir comment je peux
faire remonter la sensation la gravure
pour ça permet cet effet là
puisque on superpose les images on que
légèrement les décalés quand on refait
une réimpression par dessus on obtient
du coup un effet vibratoire qui se
rapproche un peu de la réalité c'est
aussi de pouvoir échanger à un moment
donné entre la perception du paysage que
j'ai et la perception du paysage que les
gens ont une perception à partager
gratuitement du 15 septembre au 9
octobre au min de saint denis
l'occasion de redécouvrir à travers la
gravure les variations de couleurs des
champs au cours des saisons